the master of mystic arts may be coming
face to face with an old ally and it
won't be a friendly reunion inside
sources are reporting that Baron Mordo
who became thoroughly disillusioned with
the ancient one at the end of dr.
strange will be the main antagonist of
dr. strange too though the casting is
yet to be confirmed this lines up well
with the information we do have dr.
strange too was one of the forthcoming
Marvel flicks reported to be on the way
by the mysterious twitter user Roger
Waddell and a massive leak earlier this
month while we tend to take such things
with a grain of salt the Twitter user
has leaked highly accurate information
in the past according to sources close
to we got this covered
the second solo outing for the good
doctor is in quote deep development with
the first film's director scott
derrickson and screenwriter C Robert
Cargill already hard at work according
to these sources when we next see Mordo
played by chouet elegy oh poor he'll be
in full-on villain mode intent on
ridding the world of magic while the
details of Ejiofor s contract aren't
known it's all but certain that he'll be
reprising his role given his impressive
performance in the first movie ed go4 is
a brilliant actor and in Doctor Strange
he invested more dough with a strong set
of ideals and a conflicted nature that
shone through
despite the character's relatively
limited screen time as we've seen the
MCS greatest villains aren't the ones
who simply want to cause chaos or rule
the universe it's characters like danos
who enacted a plan to wipe out half of
all life in the universe for supposedly
benevolent reasons and Loki who seems to
constantly struggle against his own
worst impulses who strike the biggest
chord among Marvel fans
Mordo began Doctor Strange as a firm
disciple of the ancient one in her ways
but was shaken by the fact that she had
harnessed the power of the Dark
Dimension while forbidding her students
to do the same his assertion during the
film's post-credit scene speaks to a new
world view because I see at long last
was wrong at the
too many suicides his new belief systems
seem to be wrapped up around the belief
that the use of magic at all even in
defense of our entire universe is to
invite catastrophe upon that universe
at any rate assuming that reports as
accurate Mordo is likely to be one of
many villains in play for Doctor Strange
to a previously from Roger Waddell has
suggested that the sequel will also take
place in the 1980s and see the
introduction of some new characters
Wardell wrote Doctor Strange to 1980s
Boogaloo tilda swinton and talks to
return is the ancient one
Jericho drum and CLIA will make their
MCU debuts CLIA will likely be portrayed
by an Asian actress most importantly the
gloves will be back we should point out
once again that none of this has been
confirmed but we expect to get a lot
more information on the MCU space for
within the next few weeks in July Marvel
will present at San Diego Comic Cons
Hall H where the studio has made a ton
of significant announcements in the past
however even Hall H may simply be a
warm-up for a second presentation to
follow at Disney's d23 Expo in August
it's quite likely that Marvel's entire
face for slate will be revealed at that
time and we can finally confirm or
debunk the seemingly never-ending
torrent of rumors which have been
leaking all year we'll be on the lookout
for any more leaks and we'll keep you
up-to-date check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the MCU were coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]